when it comes to security google cloud
is never finished
there's always room for improvement and
our newest security improvement is
providing keyless authentication
for service accounts when your
application needs to access services in
google cloud
outside of the scope of a user it
probably uses a service account
service accounts allow developers to
assign an identity to an application
and then give that identity specific
permissions for example
to access a cloud storage bucket service
account keys
are akin to user passwords allowing the
holder to act as the service account
and gain access to any resource that
surface account has access to
unfortunately there's no way to verify
that the application holding the key
has permission to use it it's a key
without an expiration date
and with no guarantee around where it's
stored or who has access to it
because of this risk managing the
storage distribution
and rotation of service account keys
becomes a top priority
effectively turning an identity
management problem into a secrets
management problem
so what's the solution ditch the keys
workload identity federation enables
applications running outside of google
cloud
to replace long-lived service account
keys with temporary credentials
also called tokens workload identity
federation is a keyless application
authentication mechanism for calling
google cloud apis
it works by first having your
application authenticate to your
identity provider
and receive account credentials the
application can then call our security
token service to exchange the account
credentials
issued by your identity provider for a
short-lived google cloud access token
this access token can then be used to
impersonate a service account
inheriting the permissions of that
service account to access google cloud
resources
to set up workload identity federation
you'll first need to create a workload
identity pool
in your google cloud project fortunately
you don't need to be a super admin to do
this
you only need permission to manage
workload identity pools service accounts
and iam policies at the project level a
workload identity pool allows you to
organize and manage external identities
a project can have multiple pools with
each one allowing access from a
different external identity provider
this allows you to create collections of
identities and easily control the
permissions granted to identities from
each identity provider
then configure a one-way trust between
your identity provider
and the workload identity pool by
providing relevant metadata about your
provider
now when an application attempts to
exchange their idp credential
the security token service will be able
to validate that the credentials from a
trusted provider
before issuing an access token to the
application
finally you'll need to create an iam
policy that allows identities in the
workload identity pool
to impersonate the service account with
these policies in place we're now set up
to properly authenticate
the application we've mitigated a
security risk while maintaining the
ability to reliably make
google cloud api requests to learn more
about how workload identity federation
can help you better protect your google
cloud access
check out the blog post to try it out
for yourself be sure to see the
documentation to start your keyless
security adventure
you